entrando y saliendo de los tribunales
rodeado de personal de seguridad Alvin
bracke está al mando de los casos
penales de la ciudad de Nueva York como
fiscal de distrito de Manhattan es la
fuerza que impulsa el juicio de Donald
Trump nativo de Harlem bracke ha dicho
siempre que el trauma de un oficial de
policía apuntando con una pistola su
cabeza a los 15 años influyó en su
pasión por la justicia después de la
facultad de derecho de Harvard y una
serie de importantes trabajos en la
fiscalía se convirtió en el primer
fiscal afroamericano de Manhattan
demócrata y uno de los cinco Fiscales de
distrito de la ciudad de Nueva York fue
elegido para el cargo En noviembre de
2021 y pronto fue señalado por abandonar
la investigación de su predecesor sobre
el patrimonio neto de Trump un caso que
creía que no se sostendría ante la Corte
pero proceso con éxito los negocios de
Trump por cargos de fraude fiscal y tras
bambalinas en el bajo Manhattan la
investigación de Daniels cobró impulso
culminando con la acusación de la semana
pasada la primera contra presidente
siguió un Frenesí mediático y protestas
al igual que rechazo Trump criticó a
bracke en las redes sociales lo calificó
de racista y parte de la izquierda
radical para él y otros legisladores
republicanos que hicieron acusaciones
similares el caso podría ser tomado como
interferencia electoral un grupo de
representantes republicanos está
solicitando detalles sobre el caso la
oficina de brack rechazó la demanda Y
dijo a su vez que se trataba de
interferencia política y legal en un
caso penal en curso uno que no está bajo
la jurisdicción del congreso